what okay so what income does a guy need
to have in order to have a wife that
stays at home so that that is the
tradeoff right is like women we provide
youth Beauty and fertility and
submissiveness in exchange for resources
because one thing you learn when you
have babies is that when you're pregnant
and when you are postpartum and when you
are nursing you are no longer a strong
independent women you need resources you
can't like if you got a baby attached to
your boob for 16 out of every 24 hours
it's really tough to go to work can you
do it can you bring a pump and be in the
break room pumping milk and freezing it
so that the nanny can feed the B yes you
can I hated it I tried doing that when
my oldest kids were little and it was a
nightmare uh I remember sitting there
trying to pump milk and just crying
because I was exhausted it was horrible
um so you do want a man with resources
if this is what you want to do